anna hazare et longtemps la mère a donné
ses meilleurs vendanges
aujourd'hui ce n'est que la plus belle
plage de la costa la balle quand
autrefois il fallait des boeufs et vieux
et les enfants suffisent à présent
attiré les filets sur la grève le
poisson a disparu mais certains samedis
il arrive que les touristes se laisse
prendre par le monde via le tourisme
c'est bien et tout le monde en profite
nous les pêcheurs l'an dernier le
tourisme a compté pour 8% et demi dans
l'airé chaussée du portugal 20 fois plus
que la pêche et ses gestes anciens
répétait à vide pour des trois
caméscopes
sont désormais payés par le syndicat
d'initiative
mon père ici grâce à ses deux montagnes
c'est une vie très dure mais c'est comme
ça
non